there is a major shake-up tonight on
president Trump's legal team his lead
attorney and Special Counsel Robert
Muller's investigation has resigned
chief intelligence correspondent
Catherine Harridge spoke to John Dowd
today about why John Dowd said he
resigned as the president's lead outside
attorney on the Russia probe this
morning and the president graciously
accepted he exclusively told Fox News
the president has a terrific case and
has proved it to the special counsel
robert muller and his team in spades
down defended his weekend statement
calling on the Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein who oversees the special
counsel robert muller to end it saying
the statement is no different than what
i have told muller and his investigators
on multiple occasions I am so proud of
the president's transparency and how
anyone could accuse him of obstruction
after the president's extraordinary
cooperation is beyond me while Dad would
not comment on legal strategy Fox News
learned there was disagreement over
whether the president should sit for an
interview with the special counsel after
signing a presidential order imposing
tariffs our reporter raised the issue
the president's outside legal team
includes Ty Cobb Jay Sekulow and earlier
this week at a former US Attorney Joe
digenova while top litigator Ted Olson
turned down an offer down Champion
providing witnesses and records on a
voluntary basis raising the question why
the special counsel needs the
president's interview when other
accounts or documents can answer his
questions on Capitol Hill mixed reaction
and warnings I am not overwhelmed by the
allegation of obstruction of justice
what I have seen is a president who gets
fixated on the investigation and says
things that create legal issues for him
if you shut down or throttle the Muller
investigation you will plunge this
country into a constitutional crisis
another House Democrat voiced concerns
that the two-week congressional recess
is beginning and the president might
take dramatic action with lawmakers out
of town Chris Catherine the House
Intelligence Committee revealed new
information about leaks and the Russia
probe what can you tell us about that
that's right Chris the House
Intelligence Committee Republicans
released new findings from the Russia
investigation today including a section
on national security leaks that found
the former Director of National
Intelligence James clapper whose job
included protecting classified
information quote provided inconsistent
testimony about his contact with the
media including CNN based on Fox's
reporting lawmakers questioned clapper
about the January 2017 briefing on the
Trump dossier to the incoming president
and it was after that Trump Tower
briefing a leak got the dossier story
out into the mainstream media we have
reached out to DNI clapper for comment
and now of course he is a national
security analyst for CNN Chris Catherine
thank you